for many of us our experience with
virtual presentations is that they're
virtually ever really any good we're
used to seeing shots of nostrils a bunch
of background noise people reading
slides to you but it doesn't have to be
this way in fact there is a hierarchy of
virtual events from tier 0 all the way
up to tier 4 and in this video we're
going to teach you about each one of
those tiers and what it takes to pull
them off effectively if you want more
about the equipment that we use for each
one go ahead and check the blog post in
the comments and please whatever you do
let's just stop the zero effort that's
out there this is a tier 0 webinar I
have my built-in webcam built-in
microphone
you just have the upward shot my face
isn't fully in screen I've got clutter
in the background I'm backlit by a
couple of life now we are going to share
my screen your presentation here we go
tier 0 webinar and my name is antar
Carvin with humor that works go to my
first slide and this is where I have a
slide full text that I'm going to read
you I mean it means I don't memorize
anything I just read it to you the giant
disadvantage to you and to the idea in
general that's not very exciting
engaging more effective if everything I
want to say looks nice I might as well
just send you to slide deck and for a
nice walk or grab a book shaker please
take a nap note it's also particularly
bad if you have a tip oh in the slide
and that forces you to read it all
here we are for a tier 1 webinar the
technology is exactly the same as a tier
zero but the experience is already a
little bit different first of all I have
elevated or raised the camera in my
entire laptop by putting them on a stack
of books I've changed my background a
little bit I've cleaned it up a little
bit try to remove any clutter and
reframe the shot just so that we don't
have way too much light or backlight in
the frame also other differences that
you notice we try to keep things
relatively quiet also I am now wearing a
shirt at least nicer shirt button-up
shirt I had showered I have shaved I'm
gonna share my screen is part of a
presentation to have already put that
presentation into presentation mode the
tier 1 webinar my name is Anna your
Tarvin representing humor that works
there is no wall full of text I'm not
reading everything out to you word for
word it's more of a bullet point for 4x4
guidelines suggest that at most you
should have four bullet points and
ideally roughly 4 to 5 words per bullet
point you might even include a picture
something that metaphorically represents
what you're talking about but in a more
engaging way you can also start to take
advantage of things like the chat
feature encourage people to say hey in
the chat you know share on a scale of 1
to 5 how are you feeling about this type
of content now this is a tier 2 virtual
experience getting into the realm of
things like virtual workshops
immediately you already noticed a couple
of things that are different
first of all resolution is higher
because I'm using an HD webcam connected
via USB the audio is also stronger
because I'm using a USB microphone I've
attached some headphones to it as well
so that I don't get any echo or feedback
from any of the attendees when they
start talking I've elevated the entire
production to the point that I'm now
able to stand up so I'm a little bit
more free-flowing in my presentation my
backdrop is a little bit different I
found
spot that's a little bit less
distracting and also less of a
high-traffic area in my apartment and
I've even ironed my shirt not only did I
put on a nice shirt I earned it but just
the front because no one's gonna see the
back in addition to that I've also got
better experience with the technology
itself so things like going into slides
there's a lot more seamless while
sharing my screen I'm also sharing my
video encouraging people to keep that
video visible while also looking at the
text maybe even teaching them how to use
side by side mode or change the size of
the video in comparison to this slide
this is so that instead of just seeing a
static image they're also still seeing
someone who is presenting to them the
slides themselves are a little bit more
visually compelling still using bullet
points but also incorporating animation
so that the slides build over time and
there's not just one static image on the
screen I'm also doing whatever it is
that I can to defend against death by
PowerPoint that might include things
like incorporating a little bit of humor
perhaps sharing a funny picture of a
sign that you've seen I'm also taking
advantage of some more advanced webinar
technology in addition to encouraging
people to use the chat by giving them
various prompts such as on a scale of 1
5 or type Y for yes in for no or just
asking simple questions of like where
are you dialing in from today I'm also
making use of things like polls and
breakout rooms breakout rooms give you
an opportunity to pair people up in
groups of 2 3 4 or beyond to create a
little bit more engagement and an
opportunity for networking all of these
things help to create a more engaging
experience that isn't just sitting at
your desk waiting for someone to stop
talking this is now a tier 3 virtual
experience already you're noticing that
it is a little bit visually different
than what we've seen before first of all
it's a wide-angle camera shot do you
actually see whether or not I'm wearing
pants not only am i wearing pants I'm
wearing my ironed shirt a blazer and a
belt well is the last time you had to
put a belt on in addition to this angle
I also have an up close more intimate
angle that I can switch to have also got
slides that I can switch to
pretty quickly and easily notice that
there wasn't any time delayed to share
the screen but rather went right into
the slide switched on my side I can also
go into this picture and picture view
where you see not only just my slides
but also me while talking about those
slides slides themselves have a more
advanced design in addition to images
I'm using things like icons as a way to
represent the text
I've still got pictures that I'm using
and it might also start to incorporate a
little bit of audio as I go along
for example I'm used to hearing laughter
in my presentations and so I might
include something like a left track if I
say something hilarious like a man once
asked me if I wanted some free fish so I
asked what's the catch actually probably
not a great idea I would use it way too
much everything that we're doing from a
production standpoint is higher level so
we've got HD cameras connected via HDMI
I've got a hardware switcher switching
in between each of those different
elements Audio is done via lapel so it's
just my voice that you hear got
headphones in so I can still hear what's
going on in the meeting itself but they
are less obtrusive more hidden back and
lighting is a little bit better and all
this is done in a seamless manner where
the technology feels like part of the
experience this allows me to still do
some interactive things in the chat to
engage people with things like breakout
room polling functionality and all of
this is done to create a more engaging
experience something that feels
different than a webinar or a workshop
feels more like a virtual keynote more
like that main stage it has room for
inspiration engagement humor and I'm
wearing a belt
up next is a tier 4 experience which is
actually something that I can't create
because that requires a studio requires
more hands-on equipment it's something
that people like Dan Thurman bingeing
and drew Davis are doing incredibly well
where they're seamlessly integrating
multiple camera angles from HD cameras
very good audio they're switching in
between different types of scenes so you
can see them juggle or do magic or use a
light board they're also perhaps
including pre produced videos seamlessly
going in and out of a live experience
chatting with the audience into
something pre-recorded and all of this
has done an extremely high-level
seamlessly working because they have a
virtual producer on-site producer of
they've just done enough rehearsals that
everything works just as you would
expect you don't have to have a tier 4
to have something that is engaging
doesn't even necessarily have to be tier
3 or tier 2 at a minimum we can all
aspire to tier 1 I mean all raise our
computers up a little bit stop the
nostril shots clear the clutter behind
us and reduce the sound we're gonna do
workshops elevate to a tier 2 experience
get an HD webcam use a USB microphone
have some headphones in so that you
don't get any feedback and start to
learn the technology so you have a
seamless use of the interactive features
that comes with it if you're looking for
then that virtual keynote experience
look at tier 3 have some HD cameras
maybe a couple of camera angles that you
can switch to and take advantage of some
of the advanced features of the tools
things like breakout rooms whiteboards
polling interactive chat and finally if
you've got the space that know how the
resources can create a tier 4 TV like
produced video for those really big
events for the really crucial moment for
those really compelling stories
hopefully you've learned something from
this if you're interested in learning
more we have a link to a blog post in
the comments that shares more details
about each of the tiers as well as links
to some of the equipment that we use to
make sure that we can pull them all if
you want to learn more about all of this
not just the production but also the
content
and delivery you can sign up for our
effective or virtual presentations
workshop where you learn all the ins and
outs of how to execute this for yourself
for your own meetings and for your own
audience I think at this point I'm
supposed to say don't forget to
subscribe or hit the like button maybe
leave a comment on what you like for us
to cover as well but in the meantime
thanks for watching